Always Sunny in Philadelphia we both did
the first season you did the pilot I
love those guys I love that wrexham show
about the soccer team it's brilliant
mcelhaney's awesome he used to sleep on
my couch I don't know why he only gave
me one episode of sunny but he did thank
you Rob I love you um he's not listening
and um
but that's a show which I told him on
the podcast which I don't know if he
appreciated but I'm very you know candid
and open I said
I did that I go yeah of course I'll do
that
this this will never do anything
what's a what I just didn't I I never
thought that that show would even I mean
it became huge
because it wasn't because of the the the
quality in terms of the writing and the
fun very specific kind of humor it is
and it wasn't even that it was just like
I got there and there was I was sitting
in a chair as my trailer outside and uh
you know they had no money and uh you
know we were just like going speed of
light and it was like one take moving on
and like it was it just felt like we're
doing a student film and I was like
huh I don't I don't know what's going on
did you feel that doing the pilot I
dated Glenn in college we were what did
I know this I don't know I feel like
maybe you did Glenn finish
uh we know I don't think we talked about
I I don't know we were boyfriend
girlfriend most of college actually you
went to Juilliard
yeah
and then I met and then we moved out
here he told me about the show when him
and Rob were and Charlie were like
creating this and this is what I mean
about guys and girls
I wouldn't think to do that I was 22 and
I was like I what am I going to do
between auditions like I have to wait
for somebody to call me and send me an
audition these guys were out there
making [__] they were like they borrowed
a camera they would film things they
lived on like Crescent Heights or
glendid and they would like film things
up and down and I was like what a bunch
of losers you know like
but they're being creative they're using
their smarts they're I mean why can't
why not why can't they do that right
like I just did not give myself the
permission and they did and they did it
and I'm like I think that's awesome it
was such a that was such a huge lesson
to me watching them go through that
process so I was not even in the pilot I
was in the
um what would you call it the three
presentation Sizzle Sizzle Sizzle
whatever they shot a pilot themselves to
show it to three Arts to go hey will you
help us produce this thing and then they
remade the pilot and I couldn't do it
um but
when we were doing that I was like this
is so stupid
but I had a great time and then seeing
it later I was like yeah of course it's
their humor it's hilarious like it is
who they are and they did it like they
did it all by themselves it comes to
show you folks that
you can do it yourself especially
nowadays with the iPhone and we talk
about it all the time it should more
important you should just go shoot
everything I should be going to do that
this stuff and it's just like I have you
know just go do it you have an idea
shoot it if it sucks par for the course
but if you learn something and it but
you might just hit that lightning in a
bottle